Welcome back everyone
Maximum effort
Recently, the entire main cast of the team
making Deadpool 3 like Ryan
Reynolds, Hugh Jackman, Shawn Levy,
the director, were posting
a bunch of videos with Taylor Swift,
referring to her as a co-worker.
So now everyone is wondering
if she's going to be in the movie.
There have been rumors about it
for a while now,
so I'll explain what's going on.
This was the video of them together.
lot of you still confused, like,
what is the association
between Ryan Reynolds and Taylor Swift?
It doesn't make any sense.
But a lot of you might remember
all the Taylor Swift
Deadpool pictures from years ago.
there's those the Asian goes back years.
And obviously there are a ton of cameo
scenes happening in Deadpool three
Speaking of which,
we're getting Loki season two episodes.
Later this week
I'll be doing videos for everything,
so be sure to subscribe to get all those.
My episode one by your post on Friday
they are directly set up.
What's happening in Deadpool three
But if you have no idea why Taylor Swift
would ever be spoken of
in the same sentence as Ryan Reynolds,
Like what do these two
people have in common?
Why would Hugh Jackman
also be hanging out with Taylor Swift?
Ryan Reynolds has been personal friends
with her since before the events
of the first Deadpool movie.
They go back that far,
but they became friends
because of Ryan Reynolds
wife, Blake Lively.
She's the actual association.
She was Taylor Swift's friend.
And then they all just started hanging out
like you normally do with couples.
And Ryan Reynolds
became friends with her to That's
also how we got all those pictures of Tom
Hiddleston in Taylor Swift
hanging out with Ryan Reynolds and Blake
Lively like, wait a minute,
is this some sort of crazy marvel thing
that they're working on in the background?
You might remember this from years ago.
Tom Hiddleston just had a baby
with his current wife,
who is also the main villain
in the Marvels movie.
So talk about a marvel family there.
But years before that
for like a brief hot second,
he was just going out with Taylor Swift
in real life.
So that's why Tom Hiddleston
and Ryan Reynolds
were taking pictures together
with Taylor Swift in Blake Lively.
It is a coincidence now
that Loki is crossing over with Deadpool
three like the circle of Easter Eggs
is now complete.
But years and years ago,
Ryan Reynolds becomes friends with her.
Then he makes the first Deadpool movie.
It blows up.
And that's how Taylor Swift wound up
wearing the Deadpool costume
several years ago.
This is actually Ryan Reynolds
real life Deadpool costume
that he wore in the movie,
and he just loaned it to her for fun.
this picture was taken right after the
first Deadpool movie came out like this.
Wolverine went crazy, like,
wait a minute, is Taylor Swift
going to be in the Deadpool movies now?
What's going on?
This doesn't make any sense At the time,
people just had made the connection
through Ryan Reynolds wife, Blake
Lively, like, Oh, it's Blake Lively.
She's friends with,
and she just happens to be friends
with Ryan Reynolds because of that.
everyone wondered if she was going to
show up in Deadpool two in a cameo scene.
Obviously,
she did not, at least none that I spotted.
you can rewatch that movie
like ten more times
and tell me if you think you see
Taylor Swift in the background somewhere.
but they all continue to be close friends.
Then the rumors about Taylor Swift
having a cameo as Dazzler in X-Men
Apocalypse, when the producer of the movie
Simon Kinberg here
posted this picture of her
hanging out with the X-Men Apocalypse team
while they were making the movie,
there did wind up being a Dazzler
Easter Egg in the movie.
Like it was kind of a cameo scene was more
of like a tongue in cheek kind of thing.
Blink and you'll miss it.
But in the final cut, they cut a way down
when they were in the mall hanging out,
looking at records.
Cyclops pulls out one of Dowland's records
and shows it to Sophie Turner's
Jean Gray.
The cover art for
the album is an Easter egg for the Dazzler
issue of the X-Men comics in real life.
But it's not Taylor Swift
as Dazzler on the cover.
They're So go back to that Deadpool
three Taylor Swift video of them all
hanging out together. Zoom
enhanced in the background.
You also see Sophie Turner here
hanging out with them in present day,
like, wait a minute,
what's going on with Sophie Turner?
Is she going to be in Deadpool three?
Now, do what I think was happening
at the time is that Taylor Swift
just became friends with Sophie Turner
in real life while they were making X-Men
Apocalypse or sometime
before they started making that movie.
And that's why
she was hanging out with them,
because she was friends with Sophie Turner
that's why in present day,
you see all these pictures
and videos of Sophie Turner hanging out
with Taylor Swift, in at least as
far as I know, Sophie Turner's Jean Gray
is not supposed to be in Deadpool three.
It's going to be Funko
Janssen's version of Jean Gray.
but behind the scenes
all the dazzler stuff
just continues through the X-Men movies.
So they get to the making of X-Men
Dark Phenix.
They actually did.
Dazzler is a real character this time,
but it was not Taylor
Swift playing the character.
You do see a quick scene of her
singing at a celebration
in the backyard of the mansion,
and that's about it.
I don't remember hearing any rumors about
Taylor Swift being in Deadpool three.
Is Dazzler
until recently, like it was all this stuff
that just kind of set this up.
There have been tons of reports
about all the X-Men cameos
since the other classic Fox Marvel movies
characters coming back.
but at least right now,
if even half the rumors are true,
the Deadpool three movie's already
super stuffed with cameo scenes.
For the most part, the biggest cameo
scenes are supposed to go to
those original X-Men
movie actors like Jean Gray, Phenix, Halle
Berry's Storm, James Martian Cyclops,
Ian McKellen's, Magneto
there'll be a bunch of others
on top of that.
And we know
the TVA characters from the Loki
series will be important to the plot in.
Tom Hiddleston was also supposed to have
filmed a couple of scenes for the movie.
So usually when I see crazier rumors
like this,
like Taylor Swift is Dazzler in Deadpool
three, I'm a little more skeptical,
but the movie is going to be legit crazy,
so it wouldn't be totally out of pocket
for them to reach for a wild
or cameo like this.
But I would not recommend
holding your breath.
Like, do not be surprised if Taylor Swift
is not in the movie, well Ryan
Reynolds might do is he might just borrow
some of her music for the soundtrack.
And like,
that's the Taylor Swift Association.
Maybe in real life
he films a really meta promo with her
like he did during Deadpool two.
I also think part of the reason
why the entire Deadpool
three team was at that Chiefs
game with her was mostly for fun
because the actors strike
was still going on at the time
and it looks like that's going to be
resolved in the next couple of weeks.
the writers strike just ended recently
and they can legit
start working on parts of the movie again,
like Ryan Reynolds
concert, punching up the script,
the jokes, polishing everything.
so most of them except for Hugh Jackman,
because he's not a producer,
a writer on the movie,
but like Shawn Levy is the director,
He and Ryan Reynolds
can basically go back to work now.
so they were all just having one last big
fun outing before going back to work.
And Hugh Jackman,
like literally as I'm posting
this video, also just posted
a funny training video of him
trying to get back in shape for the movie
because
he also expects to have to go back to work
and start filming the movie again
by next week or so.
Let me know in the comments, though,
if you want to see a Taylor Swift Dazzler
cameo scene in Deadpool three I don't
think would really affect the plot.
I think it would just be
a funny cameo scene,
but it would definitely get armies of her
fans out to see the movie
and they're definitely hyping up Deadpool
three to be $1,000,000,000 Avengers
endgame level movie.
So they want everyone on the planet
to go see this film, the movie
sort of going to be a Spider-Man
No Way home kind of film
for those classic X-Men movies.
The director, Shawn Levy,
also said they'd be heavily
revisiting the legacy of the Fox
X-Men movies during that film, meaning
that they would be bringing back
a lot of those characters.
there's also rumors that he's
going to be the one to direct secret wars
because they're kind of doing
the same thing with that movie,
only with more cameos and bigger stakes.
the actual Dazzler character is a huge cut
from those old X-Men comics.
Originally, the joke in the fandom
was that in the early eighties
when she debuted, she was created only
for the purposes of selling more merch
like it was all just a marketing thing.
sell more Marvel merch,
sell more music records,
and they're not totally wrong about that.
The character was literally created
as a joint venture like corporate synergy
quote unquote, between Marvel Comics
and Casablanca Records, a music company.
the idea was, is that Marvel Comics
would write stories for the character
like you would normally do for comic book
characters, and they would also create
real life albums as if the character
were making their own albums.
So you'd buy the Dazzler
comic book, learn about her story,
but then you'd buy the Dazzler album
in real life, which cost way more money,
making them way more money.
Eventually their corporate partnership
ended, and Marvel stopped writing
Casablanca Records
into the Dazzler comics,
and she just became
more of an actual comic book character.
but it was an early example of Marvel
trying to do these cross-platform media
integrations across comics.
Eventually they got better at doing stuff
like this.
early on, the most famous example of this
was just a few years later
in the 1980s version of Secret Wars.
It was kind of like Shadows of the Empire
was for Star Wars in the nineties.
Like we don't have a movie coming out, but
we want to sell a bunch of merchandise.
so we need to create this giant
crossover story with all the characters.
this was basically an example of Marvel
doing a giant Avengers
movie before they were doing
giant Avengers movies.
the whole idea is that
you read the Secret Wars comic book
and they sell a bunch of toys
that people would run out and buy.
It did wind up making them a bunch
of extra money so it was successful.
present day, though, movies
have largely taken over this role,
like where they released Avengers Endgame.
It's super popular.
Everybody buys movie tickets,
but then the kids run out
to buy the comics for the characters,
increasing the sales of the comics.
they buy the toys for the characters,
making them way more money.
Marvel has always
typically earned way more money on toy
sales than on comic book sales.
there's all the other tie in merch
that just generally movies
are like the central role
in this moneymaking scheme
that all movie studios have.
It's not just Marvel.
It's like DC Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles, pretty much every younger
focused, giant brand.
Barbie is probably the best recent
example of that, too.
Like literally it started out as a toy
that they're turning into a movie.
So it's kind of going in reverse.
Deadpool has joked about this phenomenon
in the previous movies
like just doing things to make more money
The Secret Wars movie is going to be kind
of a combination
of the classic secret wars
with the more modern version,
but Deadpool three is meant to directly
set that movie up.
The difference with Avengers
five Qin Dynasty is this mostly like
the 616 main Avengers in the main universe
fighting the dynasty of Kings,
the Council of Kings, Secret Wars
is mostly going to be about the TVA,
saving as many people from the multiverse,
from the incursions as it collapses,
putting them on a planet
that will be their battle world
that might wind up being the void planet
just because that makes sense.
most of the characters that the TVA sees
will be from those other universes
will be like the legacy actors
from the Fox Marvel movies
and the classic Spider-Man movies,
for instance, Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man is supposed to be one of the
leaders of that multiverse Avengers team.
So it's almost like they're doing
a live action version of that Spider-Man,
the animated series Secret Wars episode.
Like you have to picture Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man
being the one to do all this,
putting the team together,
now that most of the strike stuff
has been resolved
and people are actually making movies
again,
most are getting more footage
from Deadpool three.
And once that movie comes out,
we'll learn more about Secret Wars.
Of course, they'll do more videos
and we'll probably get some Easter Eggs
for that. During the Loki season,
two episodes.
my fall Loki Season 2
Episode 1 Video We'll post Friday
My Ahsoka finale video we'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts from our channel
so you don't miss those.
Click here for that Ahsoka finale video
and click here for that Loki Season 2
Episode 1 video or update the links
as soon as I post those
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and maximum ever!